[Musique]
ils peuvent avoir quelques regrets de
jeune britannique de 19 et 21 ans qui
joue tout le temps le même numéro
ils ont cru gagner en voyant le tirage
de l'euromillion mais la jeune femme
avait cette fois oublié d'acheter son
ticket hebdomadaire une mésaventure qui
les fait passer à côté de 210 millions
d'euros
je vous présente à wind tu mairie
mécanicien aéronautique bolivien en 2016
il fait partie des six miraculé d'un
crash aérien qui décime un club de
football brésilien et avant-hier il
survit à un incroyable et dramatique
accident d'autocar dans son pays le plus
imaginer tombe dans un ravin de 150
mètres de haut 21 morts et lui et bien
il est juste et blessé au génie comment
claude et mélissa existe que j'ai un
ange gardien et c'est la vérité dans le
car j'ai ressenti la même chose que
pendant le crash
j'ai rampé pour sortir de la carcasse
comme j'avais fait dans l'avion j'ai été
le premier prise en charge par les
secours
sa joie elle est communicative alors
tout simplement
il vient de se faire vacciner contre le
coronavirus il a envie de transmettre
son plaisir pour la santé et le
bien-être de tous et sa vidéo a été vue
plus d'un million de fois en quelques
heures
ça donne envie de se faire vacciner non
oui
crush crush
ces territoires c'était pas comme hutin
on dit pas crash johnny cash non mais
c'est quoi encore ouais confiner le
département du pas de calais pendant les
prochains week-ends une idée qui rend
les calaisiens sceptiques
moi je pense que ça va rien changer
toute façon si les gens veulent ne pas
respecter et respecteront pas on a déjà
pas beaucoup de vies en ce moment donc
si en plus on doit rester chez nous le
week-end ça peut être évident pour bon
fait suffisant c'est ce qu'on fait pour
le week-end on va le faire en semaine
tant de français en souffrance clotilde
chiffres du jour oui qui montrent que
nous n'allons globalement pas très bien
12 millions de français seraient touchés
par des troubles psychiques
il faudrait détaillé mais seulement la
moitié de ces français touchés par des
troubles psychiques vont consulter des
psys n'a pas de soi la maman dans la
mare il n'y a pas de soin les gens qui
meurent quand vous le 25 mai à sion
c'est 25 de personnes n'y a pas de sous
et diakhaté soignants j'ai moi aussi
tous les jours est ce que les personnels
considère les jours est ce que c'est il
faut simplement les conneries ça serait
ce qu'à défaut de tenues vous pouvez
voir un peu de retenue en hutte où vous
ridiculisez sociaux vous pourrez
découvrir aux nations de parler de mes
visites vous ridiculiser tout à l'heure
où les prises et les personnes assurées
les policiers californiens ont failli se
faire avoir par ce mannequin plus vrai
que nature
info passagers avec casquette et masques
installé par un conducteur américain
pour rouler sur la voie de circulation
réservées au covoiturage
le fraudeur a écopé d'une amende de 400
euros comme tous ceux avant lui qui ont
tenté cette astuce ils sont nombreux et
souvent relayées par les patrouilles sur
les réseaux sociaux
et certains sont plus audacieux que
d'autres ces décisions ont été prises
c'est en novembre on est à plus de 50
milles contamination par jour et qu'il
fallait au plur un positif pas qu'on lui
amène à l'aîné c'est chiant franchement
et le jeans et ses murs des aliments
moi j'ai de la porte c'est chiant mais
bon non mais franchement le site
internet kebab frites.com site de
référence en la matière vient de publier
son classement annuel classement basé
sur les avis des clients des internautes
invités à noter selon différents
critères l'accueil hygiène la qualité de
la viande
alors quelle est donc cette spécialité
culinaire tatoué sur les fesses d'alan
est si lourde à digérer des attitudes et
afin qu'ils valent mais c'est
complètement stupide verdict cette année
c'est dans le nord qu'on trouve les
meilleurs kebab
c'est le kebab linois lillois pardon qui
s'appelle l'unique qui arrive en tête du
classement est très bien contrairement à
ce que tu pensé arrêter de manger des
kebabs depuis que je ne dis plus à lille
c'est vrai qu'il est incroyable planche
maintenant sur des toilettes
intelligentes qui nous garantisse notre
bonne santé qui la garantie comment est
bien avec des capteurs qui vont par
exemple analysé l'état de notre peau en
contact avec des lunettes connectés dans
une sorte de peau à peau analyser aussi
l'odeur des excréments et puis collecter
outre les informations issues de notre
urine pour tenter de prévenir certaines
maladies ainsi financeurs rénale ou
encore cancer de la vessie fait exact
exhausteurs de goût croissante des
[ __ ] ça qu'est ce que c'est gloucester
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être quelque chose
qui existe on trouve ma tendresse à
réussir quoique j'ai souvent je sais pas
peut-être un truc qui exauce tout 16 dit
tu veux faire un platane et une envie de
plyce exhaust ont truqué 7 le sait comme
à un remaniement
alors ces latrines 2.0 irons encore plus
loin en analysant aussi vaut celle du
jour pour vous intégrez vous indiquez le
régime alimentaire adapté comment eh
bien on vous envoyant directement asm s
sas et les toilettes qui vous envahit
sms lorsque vous êtes en osant rayons de
supermarchés pour mieux vous aiguiller
vous imaginez dans le futur ce sont donc
les wc qui feront l'analyse des courbes
france a nommé mon art est vraiment
malade mais là tous risques c'est ce
sweat alors ouais c'est bien une idée oc
génie des choses alors est ce que tu
vois quoi ressemble un jeu concours je
suis désolé comme sur un objet
ma foi je peux lui tend une poche ou
ailleurs alors vous êtes assez discret
sur votre vie privée sentimentale etc
on connaît vos rapports dans la musique
avec les femmes que ce soit dans
l'équipe ou dans les sons quels sont vos
rapports en privé et dans l'intimité une
position rêvée une véritable addiction
au sexe c'est quelque chose qui est
toujours sous tendue par des phénomènes
psychologiques de type angoisse très
forte à mal être profond
un problème de personnalité un manque de
confiance en soi pathologique et ce sont
donc des facteurs qu'il faut repérer
pour pouvoir en sortir et ibarra bon
mais ça fait un peu jouets érotiques ou
suppôts ou suppôts mais en tout cas
c'était la forme faisait que attendu
anachronique ça serait passé tout seul
ça vaut on a vu plus gros excusez nous
mais c'est moi
il faut arrêter ça sera coupé ça j'en
messieurs bonsoir merci merci d'être là
koné seydou ba oui vous l'aimez bien
humainement je sais pas mais j'aime pas
ça soit honnête
moi je n'aime pas badie le mais je te
connais pas humainement donc je peux pas
t'aider je peux pas dire si je t'aime ou
pas grâce à mon allure
je me sens tellement bien que je porte
un vêtement même à 5 euros
on a l'impression que je porte un
vêtement à 100 euros
tabbee un groupe je pense que c'est puis
la conscience et tu peux du mars et si
sa part appelé les chevilles qui enflent
1 j'espère que tu vas passer dans le
pantalon aux motifs quand même je
déteste aller ils étaient cueillis
filets des vérités qui sont pas bonnes à
dire
ou parce que vous avez quelque chose à
dire à jean beitia voilà sur un truc